Let us now abstract from
our previous example
and provide a general definition
of what a discrete time,
finite state Markov chain is.
First, central in the
description of a Markov process
is the concept of a state, which
describes the current situation
of a system we
are interested in.
For example, in the case of
the checkout counter example,
the number of
customers in the queue
provided the right
level of information
needed to define a useful state.
Time is assumed to
be discrete, that is,
divided in discrete time steps.
The system starts at time
0 in an initial state,
and at each
successive time step,
the system goes from
its current state
to a next one chosen
with some randomness.
As a result, after
n such transitions,
the state of the
system will be random,
and so we can think of
it as a random variable.
Let Xn be this random variable.
That is, Xn represents the
state in which the system is
after n transitions from an
initial state in which it
started to operate.
As a shortcut, we
may often say that Xn
is the state of the
system at time n.
We suppose that there
is a finite number
of possible states for
the system to be in.
Here, we have drawn a portion
of a finite state space
with m possible states
labeled 1 to m, using i
and j as generic labels.
Of course, we could think of
systems with an infinite number
of states, either
discrete or continuous,
but this is a bit
more complicated,
and so in this course,
we restrict ourselves
to a finite state space.
Note that the initial
state could itself
be fixed or chosen randomly.
Assume now that the system
started in state three.
What will happen next?
The system will evolve
according to one
of the possible transitions
out of state three,
for example, one of these arcs.
Note here that we don't have
an arc from three to four.
As a convention, we
only include arcs
for transitions that can happen.
Remember the checkout
counter example.
Because of our assumptions
that no more than one
person can join the
queue at any time,
we didn't have arcs
of the type going
from one to three
or from two to ten.
Also, because of the customers
being served one at a time,
departures were limited
to one person at a time,
and so no arcs of the
type going from two
to zero or from nine to two.
So the next transition
out of three
can be thought of a random
jump where, from state three,
the system will jump to either
state one, state two, state j,
or jump unto itself.
These will be the
only possibilities.
We want to describe the
statistics of these jumps,
and we will use
conditional probabilities.
Given that at time
zero, the system
is in state three,
what is the probability
that it will be in state j next?
These will be called
transition probabilities.
For example, the probability
of going from three to one
will be p31.
Here, p32, here,
p33, and here, p3j.
Note that these are
the only possibilities.
As a result, you have p31
plus p32 plus p33 plus p3j
will be 1.
Assume that the system
continued to evolve,
and after various
different steps, come back
in three at time n.
Again, what will happen next?
Well, this property here
says that the probability
of going from state three
to one is again p31,
the same as before.
In other words,
here, we will say
that the chain is
time homogeneous.
That is, these
transition probabilities
will be the same
irrespective of the time.
So this is true for all n.
And the summation that
we have written here
for the special case
is of course general.
What we have is that the
probability of i to j,
If you sum all of
these probabilities
for all possible j's,
you will have one.
Now, in order for this
probabilistic specification
to make sense and
be coherent, we
need to make a big assumption
about the evolution
of the state of the system.
This assumption, the
so-called Markov property,
given in words here and in
mathematical statement here,
is in fact, the defining nature
of what a Markov process is.
In words, what it says is
that every time the system
finds itself in state three,
the transition probability
of going to state
one will always
be p31, no matter how
the system evolved
in the past up to
being in state three.
In other words, no matter
what path the system
has followed up to
the current state,
the next state
transition probability
will be the same,
independent of that past.
Mathematically, conditionally
on knowing your current state,
having more information
about the past state
variables does not change
the transition probability
to your next state.
In other words, the probability
distribution of the next state,
X n+1, depends on the past
only through the value
of the present state, Xn.
So you can see that as the
definition of the transition
probability and that
property, that equality
from here to here, being
the Markov property.
For this property to hold
in any modeling application,
you need to choose
your state carefully.
You want to ensure that
the information contained
in the description of
your state captures
all the relevant information
to make predictions
about the future evolution.
Now, given a system,
how to properly define
the state variables
which will allow
us to model its evolution
as a Markov process
is somewhat of an
art, and there are
no cookbook recipes to do it.
However, with a little bit
of experience and practice,
one quickly gets the required
intuition to do this properly.
You will be able to
do so in that class.